[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en 1982 quel est Wilson un chercheur
physique reçoit le prix Nobel de
physique pour ses contributions à
l'étude des transitions de phase
les transitions de face sont des
phénomènes très intéressants et très
variés qui apparaissent quand on étudie
certains systèmes physiques
on peut citer plusieurs exemples
évidemment l'eau passe de l'état liquide
à la gazeux quand on fait varier la
température
le faire qui perd ses propriétés
démantations aussi d'une certaine
température ou encore le plomb qui
devient un matériau supraconducteur en
dessous d'une certaine température
c'est ce phénomène qui est à l'origine
de ce belles images où on peut voir un
aimant spontanément lévité au dessus
d'un matériau super conducteur ce qu'on
appelle l'effet maïsna
même si il est assez joli et très
intéressant de voir notre matériau
changer à vue d'oeil à l'échelle
macroscopique il est aussi assez
intéressant de voir comment cette
transition s'opère à l'échelle
microscopique lorsqu'on considère le
système comme une collection d'un grand
nombre de particules qui interagissent
les unes avec les autres
c'est le rôle de la physique statistique
on départ déficients comme Maxwell
oullsman le 19e siècle des DJ ce genre
de système
c'est une approche assez intéressante la
physique statistique faire je suis
contente de description en moyenne avec
des outils statistiques donc des
descriptions macroscopiques qui est
assez économe ce qui en fait un objet
épistémologique assez intéressant
de voir les modèles très riches qui sont
associés la physique statistique
intéresse beaucoup les mathématiciens
notamment les probabilistes dont je fais
partie à travers la
c'est un domaine de recherche très actif
et très riche ainsi qu'une des théories
les plus politiques de l'histoire de la
science
elle a également le bon goût d'avoir des
liens avec d'autres domaines comme
l'informatique ou encore les systèmes
sociaux et c'est de ce lien moi
j'aimerais vous parler aujourd'hui et
tâcher du transmettre quelques idées
quelques idées principales
la physique statistique est capable de
représenter les systèmes sociaux
en effet on peut partir de l'idée que
lorsqu'on possède un modèle de physique
statistique qui représente disons des
particules par des objets mathématiques
on peut remplacer cette interprétation
par une interprétation d'individus
remplacer les particules par des
individus dans le modèle et cela nous
fournit un modèle de système social
ça peut sembler pas forcément très
efficace mais j'aimerais vous montrer
que dans certains cas ça peut être
intéressant
plus j'ai lavalement j'aimerais vraiment
qu'il y a des aspects universels dans la
manière dont les objets se rassemblent
s'agrège et que certains de ces modèles
permettent de mettre ses aspects
universels en lumière
nous allons voir quelques fois où ces
représentations peuvent être
intéressantes
en 1967 stavien
social surtout connu pour sa fameuse
expérience de soumission l'autorité avec
les décharges électriques
propose une expérience aux Etats-Unis ce
sera plus tard connu sous le nom
d'expérience du petit monde
le principe est simple une personne est
désignée au hasard et reçoit un document
contenant des informations sur une autre
personne appelée personne cible
le but était de retrouver cette personne
en suivant quelques règles qui étaient
situées dans le document
la première règle stipule qu'il ne faut
pas chercher à contacter la personne
cible si on ne la connais pas
personnellement à la place il faut
sauter le document à une personne plus
susceptible que nous de la connaître
jusqu'à retrouver éventuellement cette
personne
la deuxième règle que chaque personne
qui reçoit le document doit être son nom
de telle sorte en bout de course il soit
possible de mesurer la distance entre la
première personne et la personne civile
je parle de distance parce que c'est
comme cela qu'on appelle
cette quantité dans la modélisation
mathématique la plus courante pour ce
genre de situation celle qui utilise des
graves
un grave c'est un objet mathématique
assez général qui consiste pendant une
collection d'ensemble de points qui sont
reliés entre eux par des arêtes
un objet assez général qui est souvent
utilisé en informatique notamment
une application fréquente des graves
consiste à représenter les individus par
des sommets et les relier entre eux par
des arêtes parce qu'ils se connaissent
personnellement
l'expérience de migrants n'avait alors
pour but de mesurer
et on appelle distance le nombre minimal
d'arêtes à traverser pour passer d'un
sommet à un autre donc ici sur ce bras
par exemple la distance entre 5 et 6
c'est
donc dans l'expérience de Milgram
il est le but était de mesurer la
distance sous le graphe des États-Unis
beaucoup de chaînes n'ont pas abouti
dans ce qu'ils ont lancé mais plus d'une
soixantaine ont atteint leur personne
cible et il a alors été possible de
mesurer la distance moyenne est-ce que
vous avez une idée du résultat obtenu
le respect est entre 5 et 6
et c'est vraiment minuscule quand on se
rappelle qu'il y avait 200 millions
d'habitants aux États-Unis à cette
époque
même s'il y a beaucoup à dire tant au
niveau de la méthodologie que de
l'interprétation des résultats ça c'est
important
elle laisse à penser cette expérience
que le monde est un petit monde
ou plus précisément qu'en moyenne deux
individus choisis au hasard sont reliés
par un chemin très très court
une expérience centrale me semble
l'approche de compréhension des réseaux
humains et nous allons voir comment le
monde de la recherche a essayé de
s'emparer cette question
lorsqu'on essaye de représenter un
réseau humain par un graphe on peut
penser à plusieurs candidats
on peut penser au graphes réguliers
comme les quadrillages comment on se
prend envie de compte que ce ne sont pas
des très bon candidats car c'est supposé
un peu trop d'uniformité sur les réseaux
humains et de plus ils veulent à
reproduire la propriété de petites
distances qu'on a vu dans l'expérience
des migramme
d'autres candidats sont les graphes
aléatoires
qu'on a conçu au hasard
on peut les construire comme prenant un
ensemble de points et de décider de
relier chaque carte de France selon le
résultat d'un ancienneté
ce qui va donner une structure très
aléatoire
c'est grave présente la propriété de
petits monde de petites distances mais
il fait à reproduire une autre propriété
très présent dans les réseaux humains la
propriété de grand coefficient de custom
grâce avec un grand collection prétoring
Instagram qui a présenté beaucoup de
cluster
donc si les individus parmi nous nous
formons grâce avec un grand position si
deux personnes parmi vous me connaissent
il y a de fortes chances que vous
connaissiez entre vous également
on peut reformuler cette idée par dans
les réduits humains dans la manière dont
les individus s'organisent ils ont de
fortes tendance à créer des communautés
en 1998 les chercheurs battent ont
montré dans un article d'importance
majeur que beaucoup de réseaux à la fois
d'origine humaine mais naturelle
présentait ces deux caractéristiques on
appelle la propriété de petit monde
on peut citer le réseau d'acteurs de
cinéma ou deux acteurs qui ont joué dans
un même film sont reliés entre eux
le réseau de la collaboration
scientifique ou deux chercheurs qui ont
coécrit un article ensemble sont reliés
entre eux
ou encore la structure neuronale du
cerveau d'un verre je ne voudrais pas
prononcer le nom
présente encore cette propriété de
petits membres
c'est des travaux ces études ont
également pu être menées sur des réseaux
sociaux géants comme facebook avec plus
de 700 millions d'utilisateurs 70
milliards de liens
la conclusion était que le monde de
Facebook est dans le monde encore plus
petit
que le monde dans lequel nous vivions
avec une Grammes avec une distance
moyenne entre 4 et 5
je pourrais vous citer encore beaucoup
d'autres caractéristiques et beaucoup
d'autres exemples mais j'espère vous
avoir fait intuiter ou convaincu
qu'il y a des aspects très communs si ce
n'est universel
dans les réseaux humains
c'est un des rôles de la science de
découvrir les phénomènes universel et le
domaine d'étude qui s'intéresse au
phénomène universel dans les sociétés
humaines s'appelle la sociophysique ou
physique sociale
elle fait comprendre les phénomènes
comme la formation des communautés
l'évolution des opinions ou encore
l'évolution des langages
même si ces phénomènes restent encore
très mal compris il existe beaucoup de
modèles qui essayent de représenter
individuellement ces aspects
il y en a déjà fixe particulièrement et
dont j'aimerais vous parler aujourd'hui
c'est le modèle design
c'est un modèle initialement conçu pour
représenter des matériaux comme le faire
qui lorsqu'on fait varier à la
température vers ou acquiert des
propriétés des mentions
lorsqu'on effectue la traduction de ce
modèle en socio-chysique il devient un
modèle de dynamique des opinions et nous
allons voir comment cette traduction
s'opère sur ce modèle
ce modèle un peu naïf pour représenter
du dynamique d'opinion mais je pense
qu'il peut bien illustrer en quoi
consiste
lorsque l'on souhaite représenter un
système physique avec le modélisme on va
prendre des particules on va disposer
sur un quadrillage et on va associer des
moments magnétiques et ses particules
lorsqu'on interprète comme un modèle
socio-chysique à la place de particules
on va installer des individus sur chaque
point de vue du quadrillage et on va
associer une opinion à chacun de ces
citoyens que je représentés par une
flèche vers le haut pour oui et une
flèche dans le bas pour nous
de plus on va faire d'interagir chaque
citoyen avec 4 de ses voisins je
représentés par des flèches verts
et ces interactions vont varier avec une
intensité qui va dépendre d'un certain
paramètre
dans l'interprétation physique ce
paramètre est lié à la température mais
je vais garder cette interprétation
cette nomination dans l'interprétation
socio-che physique mais il faut garder
en tête que ça mesure la force de
l'interaction entre les individus
lorsqu'on s'amuse à faire varier la
température dans ce modèle on peut
constater qu'à haute température c'est
comme si aucun citoyen n'accordait
d'importance à l'opinion de ses voisins
on sait de manière complètement
indépendante ce qui donne une structure
très chaotique
à basse température au contraire c'est
comme si le système global voulait
atteindre un consensus que tous les
citoyens voulaient s'aligner
entre les deux à une température très
précise se perd les transition de phase
ce que nous disent modèle c'est que
lorsqu'on fait varier la force de
l'interaction entre les individus
à un moment donné
le système d'opinion va subir un
changement global drastique et
structurel
voilà très concrètement en quoi peut
consister une approche socio-chysique
maintenant qu'on a dit tout cela on peut
se poser quelques questions
notamment quel type de sa mort
dégage-t-on de toutes ces belles
théories
même si les terroristes sont imparfaites
en bien des points elles le regroupe
beaucoup d'observations qu'on peut faire
sur le monde qui nous entoure
en substance elles ne sont que ça que
des manières très éduquées de faire des
prédictions
une manière d'illustrer cela remonte à
2004 lorsque Serge gala un sociothéicien
Français cherchait à prédire le résultat
du référendum de 2005 sur la signature
de la Constitution européenne
je vous montre le l'évolution des
opinions des sondages à cette période le
nom était donné comme extrêmement
perdant mais ça je galère quand même
dessus
de par ses connaissances ont la
dynamique des opinions
il avait prédit que l'ouverture des
débats permettrait au nom de gagner en
popularité pour gagner éventuellement
il effectue à d'autres prédictions au
fur et à mesure des années sur des
élections certaines qui se vérifièrent
d'autres non
mais pour moi se tromper n'est pas très
grave car dans l'approche de la méthode
scientifique se tromper permet en effet
de perfectionner nos théorie la méthode
scientifique nous dit qu'il faut établir
des théories pour ensuite effectuer des
prédictions on compare nos observations
de nos expériences et en fonction de
cette comparaison nous allons
perfectionner nos théories
pour ça il nous faut des données et
lorsque l'on récolte des données sur les
individus pour prédire leur comportement
on peut facilement voir qu'il peut y
avoir des mauvaises utilisations et donc
la deuxième question que j'aimerais
adresser quels sont les enjeux éthiques
autour de la sociophylique
il va nécessaire que les utilisateurs
sur internet par exemple soit en accord
et conscient de l'utilisation qui est
faite de leur donner
et également de telles théories ne
mettent pas des campagnes de
désinformation ou entraver des processus
démocratiques comme dans l'affaire
Cambridge Analytica
on pourrait rapidement se dire que
prohiber ce genre de théorie on
interdire la recherche nous protégerait
de mauvaises utilisations
mais à mon avis c'est en étudiant champ
de recherche on comprendra quels peuvent
être les mauvaises utilisations de cette
théorie et comment s'en protéger
je n'ai probablement plus guère de temps
mais j'aimerais finir sur ces derniers
mois
au paraphraser à l'extrême-nand sociaux
physicien américain qui s'intéresse
notamment au même éthique
de même que nous avons été invocapulaire
économique et épidémiologique ces
dernières années je pense qu'il serait
utile d'acquérir un vocabulaire
socio-chysique utilisez des termes comme
taille de cluster corrélation entre les
opinions
degré de connexion d'un média
je pense qu'il y a carrément capillaire
vous permettrait de mieux comprendre des
phénomènes démocratiques dans lequel
nous sommes naturellement inscrits comme
les élections ou encore la lutte contre
le changement climatique à travers la
guerre des opinions qui est liée
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]